ambiance des grands jours dans ce bus ce
lundi 16 juillet les jeunes de l'étoile
sportive de travaux ont passé une
journée de rêve les trappistes vont
rencontrer l'équipe de france de
football à l'elysée pour fêter avec eux
leur titre de champion du monde puis
super super content je pense aujourd'hui
à pas plus heureux que moi et que nous
qui sont dans le camp voir de si près
comme moi quand t'es fait que didier
deschamps l'entraîneur on va y aller
chez emmanuel m'approcher au total le
club de football de trappes a obtenu 20
accréditation pour l'événement une juste
récompense pour son président d'honneur
d'abord les bénévoles d'abord les clubs
amateurs et que je sache les
professionnels viennent tous du monde
amateur pas l' inverse en milieu
d'après-midi le but s'engouffrent en
emparer entouré par des supporters de
l'équipe de france
[Applaudissements]
on passe un moment fabuleux escorté par
les motards
en cortège présidentiel ouais c'est
forcément un moment assez exceptionnel
et puis nos enfants qui sont joyeux ça
c'est quand même la récompense des
enfants joyeux c'est toujours non
compensés par des sections de plus en
plus d'un mois là c'est tout on va
chanter on va prendre des photos à tout
faire non pas encore faut que j'arrive
et des heureux ces supporters trappistes
arrive enfin à l'elysée vers 17 heures
ils rejoignent les 1300 autres jeunes
invités par le président de la
république
emmanuel macron ce jour là et enfin il
accède à la cour de l'elysée c'est un
grand moment pour nous pour le club et
moi j'ai plus de mots pour le coup je
vais laisser la parole aux enfants et on
est tous très heureux d'être là j pas
les mots straub où il a de la chance
qu'ont les enfants ont pu passer une
heure en compagnie des nouveaux
champions du monde et certains en ont
même profité pour faire quelques photos
sofiane aura 19 ans dans quatre ans
l'âge d'un certain killian mba p